chaoui vient de présenter un tout
nouveau smartphone qui vient chercher au
pot sur le réno une fois 10 et qui vient
chercher huawei sur le pétrole pro on
sait que j'ai omis font des bonds
smartphone à différents prix mais là bon
coup c'est très intéressant parce que
c'est le premier smartphone à être
photophone et a proposé cinq capteurs
dont le fameux capteur sans 8 mégapixels
ce qui est quand même énorme
c'est cette bête là c'est le minutes 10
minutes 10 ce qui est juste là que
j'utilise depuis plusieurs jours alors
on va se faire un truc très simple
aujourd'hui extrêmement simple on va
regarder déjà un peu le contenu de la
boite on va regarder ce qui est fait
d'un point de vue esthétique et on va
regarder s'il tient ses promesses en
photo et qu'est-ce qu'il peut promettre
à côté de la photo et vous allez voir
que ce smartphone c'est à dire tous ou
des photos
[Musique]
non
la promesse principale qui est fait sur
ce smartphone c'est au niveau de la
photo on le voit ici sur le petit bridge
wind bing épique choque c'est le premier
smartphone avec cinq capteurs à 100 8
mégapixels c'est énorme et monte au 64 1
mégapixels en début d'année sans 8
mégapixels qu'est ce qu'un smartphone
avec 100 8 mégapixels peut venir vous
apportez minott disent regardez moi
cette jolie petite boîte avec 7 petits
reflet bon plutôt sympa on retrouve dans
les codes de xiaomi ça marche on a raté
bien évidemment le smartphone déjà été
en boxer minimes ont juste après lorsque
vous ouvrez vous retrouvez votre
smartphone avec normalement ce petit
papier dessus qui vous donne les
premières indications une première
caméra 5 mégapixels haute résolution on
a cinq caméras pour tous les scénarios
imaginables avec un zoom hybrid ois 10
avec une stabilisation optique ça c'est
cool
un écran de 6,47 ou incurvé en trois
dimensions à molette bien et une grosse
batterie de 5000 260 millions paire eur
et de la recharge rapide 30 watts ça
c'est ce qu'on voit directement quand on
ouvre alors on suit on arrive sur le
smartphone
normalement qui est positionné juste là
comme ça avec ça vaille et hop on le
prend on enlève on regarde juste après
en dessous on se retrouve avec ce truc
là alors offre vient me chercher comme
ça vous avez de quoi ouvrir votre tiroir
de cartes sim pour trouver à l'intérieur
des notices carte de garantie
intéressant et surtout retrouver cette
petite coque en silicone alors seulement
parce qu'elle est noire cette fois ci on
reste vraiment dans l'esprit du noir
voyez men in black un petit peu très
élégant si vous regardez si je pas si
vous le voyez alors on a un côté
transparence pourtant c'est bien la
coque
elle sait bien fermé ici c'est pareil
côté transparence pourtant c'est bien
faire mais en fait ça correspond aux
antennes que vous avez ici sur le côté
et que vous avez sur le dessus on
continue à l'intérieur de la boîte il y
en a tout simplement ici son câble de
recharge en usb c'est usb son gros blocs
de recharge rapide monstrueux de 30
watts qui est là avec sept bateaux et
dans ce côté noir élégant j'aime bien
plutôt sympa assez classe humaine plutôt
très classieux comme ça bon ça
fonctionne après on est sur des gros
masi karen bien exceptionnel à
l'intérieur le boxing plutôt normal rien
d'un go mais c'est quand on arrive là
que ça devient vraiment intéressant avec
le smartphone en main parce qu'on se
rend compte qu'on apprenne aux
smartphones très grand capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran tu déverrouille assez rapidement
qui est plutôt bien mais surtout un très
grand écran de 6,47 pouces incurvé en
eau est je trouve 2
bonne qualité je trouve surtout lumineux
des couleurs qui sont bien comme on les
sort de l'amoled on a des noirs a fini
je trouve très qualitatif txomin nous
annonce une luminosité jusqu'à 6 ans dit
un écran qui protégeait contre la
lumière bleue et vous avez un corning
gorilla glass 5 à l'avant mais également
à l'arrière donc bon normalement plutôt
résistants contre je vous invite
néanmoins bien protégé parce que même
sur nos smartphones résistants vous
savez un petit caillou mis en coin quand
il tombe par terre ils n'aiment pas trop
à l'arrière vous avez trouvé cinq
modules caméra et c'est là que ça
devient vraiment très intéressant tout
en haut ici c'est votre télé objectif
pour le zoom optique x 5 x 10 l'hybride
x 50 numérique qu'une stabilisation
optique et qui ouvre à f 2.0 en dessous
vous avez un capteur de 12 mégapixels
c'est un téléobjectif pour le zoom
optique x 2 ouvre à f 2.0 et qui est lui
par contre n'est absolument pas
stabilisée mais ça je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure on retrouve en dessous
avec la vedette la star
le capteur sans 8 mégapixels avec la
techno 4xl en 1 à capteur de 1,6
micromètres stabilisation optique et qui
ouvre à f 1.69 et qui a champ de vision
de 90 degrés on continue on s'ouvre avec
un capteur 20 mégapixels celle ultra
grand-angle avec un champ de vision de
117 degré qui ouvre à f 2.2 et ont fini
en dessous avec une toute petite caméra
ici c'est pour la macro c'est le 2 méga
pixels un capteur de 1.75 micro est par
contre être figé absolument aucune
information son ouverture alors la
distance est de 2 cm à 10 cm à l'avant
juste planqué si vous avez une caméra de
30 2 mégapixels capteur de l'agglo
seamicro la technologie super pixels cas
pixels en ouvre à f 2.0
donc là on se dit ok ok j'ai beaucoup de
capteurs g5 capteur à l'arrière j'ai un
capteur à l'avant j'ai en gros si module
photo différents qu'est ce que ça va
pouvoir rien m'apporter qu'est ce que je
dois faire avec tout ça il y en a
certains qui marche parfaitement bien y
en a d'autres qui sont un peu plus voilà
plus pour l'ambiance mais en tout cas ce
qui est vraiment intéressant c'est le
tour de force qui est fait par shiomi de
venir chercher les plus grands sur la
photo il des sionistes venir talonner
les autres c'est proposer la technologie
meilleur rapport qualité prix c'est
drôle parce que si on retourne l'année
dernière et qu'on va si un concurrent
qu'on va chez google pour proposer un
smartphone apic 7 3 avec un seul capteur
c'est un ennemi de capteurs vous avez
sur le pixel 4 mais c'est pas la course
aux capteurs tandis que là on est
vraiment sur la course aux capteurs
chaque capteur va avoir son rôle défini
il y en a certains qui vont travailler
de concert et ça donne un résultat qui
est intéressant pour ne parler que de la
photo vous avez donc ici votre menu
photo c'est la faute aux standards avec
ici voyez le zoom là vous êtes sûrs en
foin vous arrivez sur un foie de briller
le x 2 il est pas stabilisée chez moi se
doit tout de suite et par contre dès que
vous arrivez sur le x 5
il est stabilisé sa marche à c'est
vachement bien après qu'ils pouvaient
venir vraiment monte monte monte x 7 x 8
x 10 x 10 ça marche encore vers l'europe
que vous montez jusqu'au x 50
c'est quand même assez stabiliser pour
venir faire des shoots dont les photos
le rendu est pas ouf mais je vous montre
ça dans quelques instants vous
redescendez vous avez jusqu à l ultra
grand-angle et ensuite vous avez mode
macro qui est juste en dessous ce qui
fait que juste dans votre petit parti
photos et bien vous allez tout utiliser
la macro ultra grand angle votre capteur
principal
même si vous n'êtes pas sur un mode
spécial 100 8 mégapixels le téléobjectif
zoom x 2lt l'objectif zoom x 5 est par
contre retrouver un mot spécial pour le
sang 8 mégapixels et vous le marque ici
vous allez souhaité 100 méga pixels
ultra hd est activée vous allez faire
des photos dans une plus grosse
résolution 12032 par neuf 1024 pixels de
résolution avec le capteur de 100 8
mégapixels lorsque vous prenez en haute
résolution alors ça va vous servir à
quoi de faire des photos en 100 8
mégapixels si c'est d'avoir un gros
fichier est d'avoir une très grosse
résolution et mais ça va tout simplement
vous servir à pouvoir venir
zoom est dans votre image à venir
récupérer sans perte de qualité sur tout
cas la promesse qu'a faite avec un gros
capteurs comme ça faire des grosses
photo quand même le général on va pas à
les imprimer qu'on va pas utiliser
combat juste visionner sur un smartphone
sur un ordinateur on sur une telle et
pourquoi pas à quoi ça sert d'avoir une
grosse définition que vous avez fait
votre photo vita mince je récupérerai
dire que cette partie là je trouve
intéressante et bien vous pouvez venir
croquer dedans alors chrome et oui mais
ça a ses limites parce que si vous venez
trop zoom évidemment ça sera pas
terrible
bien évidemment votre toujours le fameux
mode portrait qui fonctionne je vous
montre ça aussi dans quelques instants
un mode nuit et ça c'est vachement bien
vous allez voir le résultat très
surprenant panorama personnellement je
ne sais pas qui s'en sert est-ce que
vous servez du mode panorama moi
absolument pas le mode pro partiellement
justice à parce que le mode photo
standard marche bien
1 grâce à l'ia venir activer désactiver
le hdr la vidéo ça c'est intéressant
c'est parce qu'on a un petit mode qui
est assez cool ici c'est le mode blog
vous tournez des toutes petites
séquences et lui va vous les mettre bout
à bout sur une vidéo de douze secondes
vous avez votre blog activités avec de
la musique avec des effets jim boyce a
fait les effets de transition qui sont
assez rigolo avec une musique derrière
c'est un peu l'idée en fait c'est pas
révolutionnaire je pense que vous allez
rapidement vous en lasser
parce que ça fait toujours un peu la
même chose vous avez également le mot
d'embellissement pour les photos avec
les fit enfin briller sa après c'est un
grand standard de la vidéo courte on met
souvent réseaux sociaux et du ralenti
jusqu'à 960 fps
bon ça à ces histoires de se marrer pour
ce faire laissez moi prendre mon ordi
parce que pour regarder la qualité des
photos faites sur un smartphone il faut
le regarder sur un ordinateur sur un
écran que vous connaissez et pas sur un
écran de smartphone qui est plus petit
qui peut être plutôt flatteur
là au moins on va savoir exactement ce
qu'il en est bon c'est une petite balade
dans paris pour bien se rendre compte là
on commence sur le capteur principal
on est en mode photo normale on n'est
pas en mode 100 8 mégapixels voyez ça
marche quand même plutôt bien je connais
une bonne définition après il fait jour
même si c'est un temps pluvieux on joue
pas de on est en vous dis qu'ici non
stabilisé mais ça fonctionne quand même
jeu x 5 optique
ça marche très bien et là on arrive sur
le x 50 alors je vous aime montrer
directement le x 50 il est un peu effet
whaou il permet de faire des choses un
petit peu rigolote mais par contre de
suite ça lis énormément c'est vraiment
pas terrible mais ça c'est pas
uniquement du fait de ce smartphone tous
les une fois 50 sont là pour laisser un
peu what the fuck
on est capable de le faire mais le rendu
d'arrière et inexploitables et là on à
l'ultra grand pas en avant dans l'ultra
grand temps que je trouve qui marche
bien je trouve pas d'effarement je
trouve qu'il est bien travaillé caster
principal x 2 x 5 x 50 ultra-grand-angle
caster principal zoom x 2 x 5 x 5 c'est
bien les photos sont vraiment de bonne
qualité vous n'allez en tout entre 1,50
et et what the fuck mais bon c'est
rigolo je sache plus sympa 50
et là vous avez l'ultra grand temps que
que le rendu est vraiment cali là dessus
là on est sur une photo typiquement 100
8 mégapixels on peut dire ok qu'est ce
que ça doit nous apporter ce sont 8
mégapixels il regagne tout simplement on
va venir zoom et hop il nous fait un
truc net et là je trouve être un truc
qui est nette
à cette distance s'est drôlement bien
alors après je peux venir jouer
davantage mais là j'aime peindre un
petit peu en qualité ça me rajoute et du
bruit mais imaginez quand même on part
de là donc je peux venir quand même
soumet recadrer
quand même une excellente qualité ça
c'est la nacre ou alors moi la macro je
ne suis pas hyper hyper hyper hyper fera
effectivement entre 2 à 10 cm on
récupère des choses un peu rigolote mais
c'est pas terrible ça c'est 1 10 de
seconde en une assiette
bon voilà c'est marrant mais vous avez
pas à grand chose la qualité n'est pas
au fond les écouter sur un capteur de 2
mégapixels
bon voilà on va chercher la ville
là-dessus nacro également macro
également c'est pas officines mais ça
fonctionne c'est rigolo plus sur la
salle est que sur le petit citron caster
principal x 2 x 5 3 50
on a du mal à reconnaître des arbres
derrière on croit que c'est une tempête
normal son zoom x 2 x 5 soit 50 et ultra
grand-angle
là on arrive sur le mode portrait alors
le mode portrait assez intéressante
parce que je trouve qu il détache bien
il est bien fait il plutôt de bonne
qualité
parce que vous le regardez comme ça les
dés sont bien cherché et qu'on rajoute
qu on vient complexifier la scène alors
là de ce point de vue là voyez il a bien
et où raymond pousse ça marche ça
fonctionne bien
la tête sahara par contre dès qu'on
arrive sur les doigts la saga saw fit un
petit peu plus compliqué
de notre côté on est sur un processeur
milieu de gamme plus sain cela dragonne
730 g g pour gainey il fait quand même
pas mal le taf le détourage est plutôt
bien là on a quelques petits défauts ici
bon c'est moi qui suis un peu cherché le
bazar vraiment venu complexifier ici
mais sinon lorsque vous mettez sur une
photo un peu plus son art sa marche
absolument bien par contre dès qu'on
arrive en mode nuit et une bonne
répartition de la lumière il ya un beau
travail a fait d'un point de vue
logiciel là-dessus marché au mieux
pouvoir changer de seine mais ça marche
bien sûr ça vraiment bien il photos de
nuit
regardez moi cette rue c'est luce c'est
net c'est beau c'est bien rendu cela
tient à la main on n'est absolument pas
sur un pied et ça ne bouge absolument
pas ils viennent ici là je viens zoomer
x 2 et la nouvelle espèce de gros zoom
la sepa terry par contre d'un point de
vue logiciel ca voulu détruire une
espèce d'aberration là par contre c'est
vraiment vraiment horrible limite très
cartoon mais la photo nue standard
marche merveilleusement bien et même la
caméra de celle qui donne un rendu qui
est franchement bien on est sur un
smartphone qui est très équilibré au
niveau de la photo
que ce soit en plein jour jusqu'à un
zoom x 10 vous avez quelque chose qui
marche très bien
l' ultra grand-angle marche très bien la
photo de nuit marche très bien la macro
ont doublé face à strictement rien les
gros zoom au delà du x 10 c'est rigolo
mais ça sert à pas grand chose
nadeau cas smartphones qui s'inscrit
dans la lignée des photophones et qui
pour moi en tout cas
et le prend
les gros vrai photophone de chiots oui
même si je me faisais des smartphones
avec des bons appareils photo là
clairement ils viennent chercher huawei
et au pot au niveau de la photo on va
pas aller chercher un google pixels cas
parce que le traitement d'image
l'arrière est pas le même la force de
google c'est l'algorithme on va pas le
team un quart des cas d'iphone aux pros
on va pas aller aussi loin qu avec un
samsung s10 plus au samsung s 10 mai par
contre la proposition est vraiment
intéressante et surtout compris mais ça
le prix et je vous dit tout à l'heure
autre usage qui est vraiment ma dernière
scène multimédia au petit coin me résous
mais aussi peu dedans on a un écran qui
est très grand a lancé denis regrettant
que cette en cause son côté mais par
contre regarder d'un peu de vie chaud on
a beaucoup de sons on a un seul
haut-parleur qui est aussi la fille
crash extrêmement forts qui envoie très
plaisant au niveau du volume c'est bien
mais c'est pas parfait parce que lorsque
vous arrive est très gros volumes que
vous avez la musique est bien derrière
sa ceinture alors il faut savoir en fait
tu l'utilisés raisonnablement il faut
savoir le régler c'est pas la peine de
pousser le son à fond de toute façon
vous allez dire polluer votre entourage
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de son ca en
voit très très fort au niveau des boîtes
et ce qui est cool c'est que pour voir
qu'on a un tout petit peu par leur ici
eh bien ça crache extrêmement fort vous
venez réglé en fonction si vous écoutez
une partie plus parler ou une partie
plus musical même sur une partie par les
vous mettez le son à fond ça vient
tordre un petit peu réglé ça réguler le
ca marche et surtout ce qui est très
intéressant au niveau de ce smartphone
ça situe ici puisque vous avez une prise
jack prise jack qui est conservé et qui
restitue un son de qualité avec un bon
spectre une bonne dynamique ce produit
purement multimédia pour regarder des
séries pour regarder des films pour
venir jouer à des jeux
la qualité est au rendez vous je vais
regretter toujours cette petite encoche
son côté ça c'est sûr 2019 ça paraît
assez normal et des fallu faire des
choix et des compromis schumi ne pouvait
pas tirer non plus les prix complètement
vers le bas et nous intègre une petite
caméra pop up on est dans l'adn de se
retrouve en 2019 donc rien de
problématique là dessus pour des parties
de 10 me ça marche c'est assez fluide
c'est assez intéressant lors d'un point
de vue performances on a ce qu'il faut
d'ailleurs que sa dragonne 730g couple
est assis giga de ram
maintenant le seul truc que je vais
venir vraiment regretté lorsque je joue
je tiens comme ça dans la main c'est
qu'en fait votre haut parleurs et si tu
as l'air ce qui fait que lorsque je le
tiens et que je viens jouer comme ça et
bien je viens au détriment par la
défense attention mes rations positionne
la main pour vous pas venir bloquer il
faut que je prenne le smartphone et que
je veux mettre dans ce sens là mais là
ça peut paraître bizarre d'avoir leur
coach de ce côté là où tout cas je suis
pas habitué je préfère vraiment la voir
comme ça ça me paraît beaucoup mieux du
point de vue lui en cause parce que je
suis frustré d'avoir ce haut parleur là
à noter que cette gamine c'est votre
truc on a un mode jeu
là dessus que vous permet de booster les
performances au maximum pour venir
apporter une expérience complètement
optimisé
maintenant il ya un autre point qui est
très intéressant sur ce smartphone et
qui fait toute sa force et son autonomie
et sa batterie de 5000 260 millions
terreur et de la recharge rapide 30
watts ça me paraît normal que la
recharge rapide avec une grosse batterie
comme ça si vous n'aviez pas de la
recharge rapide vient de passer beaucoup
de temps à venir recharger il serait
longtemps branchez vous ne pourriez pas
l'utiliser donc ça c'est complètement
normal par rapport à ce que cherche à
faire chez eux ont mis la suisse est
plutôt intéressant parce que c'est une
batterie qui nous permet de tenir deux
jours sans aucun problème ça dépend bien
évidemment une fois de plus de vos
usages si vous passer toute la journée
dessus arrivera un moment où ça ne
tiendra pas de dire si par contre vous
avez un usage courant repos éternel
un peu plus que deux jours côté prise au
monde un smartphone qui est quand même
relativement grand il faut forcément
venir tenir à demain si vous tenez à une
seule main il ya un moment vous allez
venir galéré un petit peu pour atteindre
le haut de l'écran et faire ce que vous
voulez faire ce smartphone peu trop un
peu lourd avec ses 2 108 g
ici vous pourrez insérer une double
carte sim par contre pas d'extension
microsd vous avez 128 jir du stockage ce
qui dans l'absolu est déjà largement
suffisant pour l'ol sondés sur me why 11
points 0 point 3 basé sur un android
9 vous avez bien évidemment la
possibilité de venir paramétrer pas mal
de choses je ne vous la luminosité du
mode lecture pourrait venir active et
l'avenir un petit peu vous le jaunir
alors là tout de suite j'ai poussé un
peu à fond vous voulez vraiment là juste
et pour jusqu'à c'est un peu l'effet
lumière bleue que ce soit moins aux
rites prévenir également le planifier de
telle heure à telle heure vous avez
votre schéma de couleur automatique
saturé par défaut je conseille de mettre
automatique ça va se caler par rapport à
l'éclairage naturel peut venir
réchauffer légèrement vous avez pour moi
le meilleur combo ici automatique chaud
ça marche très bien c'est un smartphone
qui est également équipé de nfc
il fait plusieurs belles promesses déjà
la photo et en plus il tient sa promesse
donc ça c'est vraiment foule
on a un bon écran pour le multimédia
c'est parfait on a suffisamment
performante à fonder beaucoup de jeu du
placed on remarque quasiment tous les
jeux du plastoc un smartphone ans durant
avec une très grosse batterie 5268
lauper de la recharge du rap je trouve
intéressant et il est disponible en
configuration si giga de ram 128 go de
stockage otaries de 549 euros 90
centimes belle réussite de la partie au
mythe venir attaquer huawei au pot au
niveau de la photo se minutes 10 fait
plein de belles promesses et surtout le
plus important c'est qui les tient à
vous de me dire comment vous trouvez
maintenant vous
en bas en commentaire est-ce que ce
smartphone pourrait vous intéresser et
est ce que vous voyez lusage pour vous
vraiment pour vous qu'est ce que vous
feriez de ces cinq modules photo
qu'est-ce que vous iriez shooter est-ce
que vous utiliseriez plus ultra grand
angle est ce que vous aimez les grandes
photos de paysages très grand
raisonnable mais pourquoi parce que vous
utilisez le mode panorama moi
personnellement je les ai utilisés juste
pour tester mais sinon pas trop
d'intérêt
est-ce que prendre des photos en 108
mégapixels ça pourrait vous intéresser
qu'est ce que vous pensez du mode nuit
là dessus que je voulais montrer mark et
moi tout ça en bas en commentaire sur ce
je vous embrasse
et je vous dis à demain ciao